got some breaking news to bring you
tonight this just in from buckingham
palace who have announced that the queen
is to miss the state opening of
parliament tomorrow
buckingham palace says
her majesty continues to experience
episodic mobility problems we know that
has been an issue for quite a while now
getting around the queen in consultation
with her doctors uh has reluctantly
decided that we are told that she will
not attend tomorrow's state opening of
parliament let's bring in our political
correspondence uh john craig so
some clearly disappointing news there
just in from buckingham palace the
prince of wales going to take her place
for the first time yes uh she's only
missed two uh state openings of
parliament in her long reign
that was uh 59 and 1959 and 63 from
memoria when she was pregnant with first
of all prince andrew and secondly uh
prince edward uh previously the
tradition has it that the lord
chancellor uh reads uh the
queen's speech if she can't do it for
whatever reason but it will not be
dominic rob it will be prince charles
first time he's done it he's attended a
few times um sitting either sitting
alongside her or not far away but this
uh is a sad day for the queen i'm sure
she's 96 just turned 96 last month
and one has to question whether she has
possibly opened parliament for the last
time given her increasing mobility
problems it was announced a few days ago
that she
is not going to be able to attend her
own garden parties at buckingham palace
so tomorrow is the big day it's the
stating opening of parliament when the
queen reads out all the bits of
legislation
that the government's going to
bring in over the next 12 months or so
we're expecting a bumper queen speech
we're expecting for example a lot of a
bonfire of eu
rules in
legislation on post-brexit reforms uh
but
for the absolute uh abs the real
uh real uh eye-catching announcement uh
rather than pieces of legislation i
think is that the queen will be missing
let me read you the statement from the
palace we just received the queen
continues to experience epis episodic
mobility problems and in consultation
with her doctors has reluctantly decided
that she will not attend the state
opening of parliament tomorrow
at her majesty's request and with the
agreement of the relevant authorities
the prince of wales will read the
queen's speech on her majesty's behalf
with the duke of cambridge also in
attendance so a number of key words
there first of all she's reluctantly
decided she can't do it there have been
suggestions today
uh that there might be what was
described as a discreet wheelchair route
uh made available so that she would
arrive by car not in the state coach as
she used to uh but she'd be able to get
into a wheelchair when the car goes in
through the sovereign's entrance perhaps
to take her up through the royal gallery
into the house of lords chamber well
clearly that hasn't worked she would
still have had to walk into the chamber
and then sit down on the throne prince
charles we understand will go
do the usual procession uh through the
royal gal gallery um
the other key pointer there of obviously
appointed to the future prince charles
reading the statement is that the duke
of cambridge will be in attendance
prince prince william so a real break
with tradition uh a real change here her
majesty not mobile enough too frail to
do the queen's speech prince charles
reading it but with prince william there
as well so uh i really i really uh quite
sad for the queen clearly she is
reluctant as the statement says so uh uh
that's uh the big news on the eve of
tomorrow's queen speech yeah plenty of
disappointment not least for the queen
john many thanks indeed of course we'll
bring you more reaction to that as it
comes in the queen to miss the state
opening of parliament tomorrow